hello i'm peter bag i'm a contributor to
recent magazine and i've been doing
alternative humor and satirical comics
self-employed for the last 30 odd years
the hate was the name of a comic book i
did almost exclusively and buy
exclusively i meant that's almost fall i
worked on throughout the 1990s that
pretty much followed the adventures and
misadventures of semi autobiographical
character named buddy bradley and it's
what i'm by far the best known for well
i define myself as a libertarian and
i've always felt that way and thought
that way even before i knew there was a
word for it when i was younger i was
very surprised to learn that this was a
unique worldview and that there was a
word for it simply because i couldn't
believe that so many people don't
believe in freedom i remember talking to
my parents about the draft reproductive
rights things like that whatever was in
the news at the time you know it's not
like there were hardcore right-wingers
they weren't they were very moderate in
their political views i just thought it
was like these crazy others that wanted
to shove their worldview down other
people's throats and to use the force
and the weight of government to keep
people from doing stuff that they don't
like even though it's not doing them any
harm so yeah eventually i learned that
there was a word for it and that we were
considered weird being a cartoonists i'm
part of the overall artistic community
and most people in the art world tend to
lean left and it's the prevailing
worldview its the prevailing groupthink
so that people whether you're
libertarian or which is plain old
right-wing most people who feel that way
they wind up keeping quiet just because
they don't want to be criticized and
jumped on if i'm talking one-on-one and
explain myself they usually could see
where I'm coming from and understand it
and appreciate it but then once they're
away from me and they're talking the two
other fellow leftists or progressives
the if my name comes up they snap right
back to basically labeling me a right
winger that
everything is black and white your
forests are against us you're either a
left winger or right winger and they
keep throwing me to the other camp
even though socially I'm as liberal as
you could get just because I'm not in
lockstep with them they amongst
themselves they're always calling me
your right winger which is really
annoying if that that pisses me off
because it isn't true and but it's I
just got used to it I don't know what
else to say you know you used to give me
fits but I've just gotten used to that
how I wound up working for a reason I
was working for a website called suck
suck calm and then the suck went out of
business but many of their contributors
worked for recent magazine so it seemed
like it was a natural thing for me to do
something similar for a recent magazine
that I was doing for suck which mainly
was covering an event doing my own comic
book style reporting on the little
things like cartoon journalism the most
recent piece I did for a reason it was
about minimum-security women's prison it
didn't change my feelings about the drug
war personally I feel like all drugs
should be decriminalized because every
single woman I talked to there where it
was in prison at least partly for drugs
either they were caught holding or
selling it or else they were stealing
our prostituting themselves to pay for
drugs but still what made the
situation's so complicated is that a lot
of those women felt like the jail was
the best thing that could have happened
to them they couldn't imagine kicking
drugs besides going to prison
of course nine times out of ten they
could go back on drugs once they get out
most of them I can't give you a
percentage but let's say ninety percent
come from a world where going in and out
of prison being on welfare just being
Ward's of the state to some degree is
the norm not just for themselves and not
just for their families but these entire
communities they live in it's this other
part of America that thankfully I'm not
a part of but it's almost all these
women are right now I have to say it
doesn't seem to be a scary time
politically with the state of the
economy and and the government being
bankrupt I can't help but feel
pessimistic about what's going to happen
next especially since the last ten years
of
bad thing that happened I pretty much
predicted but then I have to say there
have been times in the past where also
where I was even more convinced that
things were going to get worse I can't
everyone the 90 started for some reason
I was convinced the 90s were going to be
worse than the 80s but they were better
which surprised me they were better in
almost every way at least in my opinion
you know so then I just got lazy and
naturally assumed that the the arts
would be better than the nineties and
they weren't they were worse